resident evil 7 VR mode will be
exclusive to Sony's PlayStation VR for
12 months this according to an advert
spotted on Facebook as noted in a reddit
post the small print at the bottom of
the advert indicates it could be
released for other VR platforms after a
year it reads resident evil 7 biohazard
coming in 2017 and exclusive to
PlayStation VR for 12 months as of yet
Capcom is not officially announced
resident evil 7 SB our experience for
any other platforms games wat has
contacted the company for a statement
capcom launched the vr supported
beginning our demo for resident evil 7
during e3 2016 this section the game is
a standalone prologue to the main game
and will not be featured in the final
resident evil 7 experience on sep tember
16th Capcom release an update for resin
evil sevens beginning our called the
Twilight demo it allow players to
explore more of the mysterious derelict
mansion featured within it so are you
going to jump into the virtual spookfest
of PlayStation VR let me know in the
comments section below or find me on
Twitter at irregular Dave and fully
Resident Evil news make sure you
subscribe to gamespot